Привіт і ласкаво просимо назад до серії курсів з варіаційного квантового власного значення.
Мене звати Victoria Lipinska, і в цьому відео ми розберемось, як представити
задачу VQE у формі, зрозумілій квантовому комп'ютеру.
Зазвичай задача квантової хімії формулюється через енергії
системи.
Оператор, що описує ці енергії, ми називаємо гамільтоніаном.
Спочатку нам потрібно його квантувати.
Тобто записати його мовою квантової хімії,
яка формально називається другим квантуванням.
Якщо гамільтоніан описує взаємодії ферміонів, наприклад,
енергію електронів на спінових орбіталях, ми називаємо його
ферміонним гамільтоніаном — він буде нашою відправною точкою сьогодні.
Qubits, однак, мають свою власну мову.
Оператори у світі qubits описуються операторами Паулі.
Отже, наша мета тут — виразити ферміонні оператори
через qubit-оператори.
Існує просте взаємно однозначне відповідність між
станами нуль і один для ферміонів і qubits.
Тому відображення між станами також є простим.
Однак відображення операторів дещо складніше.
Ферміонні гамільтоніани виражаються через оператори народження та
знищення.
Тому наше завдання — зробити гамільтоніан зрозумілішим для квантового комп'ютера.
гамільтоніан.
Ми скористаємось математичними інструментами, щоб відобразити ферміонний гамільтоніан
у qubit-гамільтоніан із gates.
Іншими словами, ми будемо перекладати
з мови квантової хімії на мову квантових обчислень.
Уяви два ланцюжки: один із ферміонами,
тобто мовою квантової хімії.
А інший із qubits — мовою квантових обчислень.
На перший погляд відображення здається простим, чи не так?
В обох випадках ми бачимо системи з двома рівнями.
Для ферміонів: або один ферміон знаходиться у стані,
або ферміона немає взагалі.
А для qubits: або стан 0, або стан 1.
Однак усе трохи складніше.
Різниця між ланцюжком qubits і ланцюжком ферміонів
полягає у чомусь дуже фундаментальному у фізиці: у тому, що ми називаємо симетрією обміну.
Два ферміони ніколи не можуть займати однаковий стан.
Однак для ланцюжка qubits все зовсім інакше.
Два qubits можуть обидва знаходитись в одному стані,
адже qubit — це не ферміон.
Тепер нам потрібно знайти спосіб перекладу між двома ланцюжками.
Ще у 1928 році двоє дослідників — Jordan і Wigner —
довели, що ферміонні оператори для всього ланцюжка
можуть бути точно представлені через qubit-оператори.
Це найпряміше відображення для квантового комп'ютера.
Наприклад, його можна використати для відображення заповненості
орбіталі на спін одного qubit.
На практиці це відображення для гамільтоніана дає зважену суму операторів Паулі.
Це дуже важливий факт, який я хочу, щоб ти запам'ятав,
і ми повернемось до нього в наступному модулі, де поговоримо
про те, як варіаційні circuits виконуються на квантовому комп'ютері.
Описане вище відображення означає, що якщо у нас є, наприклад,
14 ферміонних операторів, ми відобразимо задачу на 14 qubits.
На щастя, існують розумні способи зменшити кількість qubits
і використовувати менше квантових ресурсів для кращої продуктивності квантового комп'ютера.
Зазвичай у молекулярній системі ми знаємо
деякі фізичні симетрії гамільтоніана,
наприклад, загальна кількість електронів є фіксованою.
Цю інформацію можна використати для зменшення розміру задачі
без втрати будь-якої релевантної інформації.
Цей метод ми називаємо редукцією активного простору.
Він дозволяє зменшити кількість ресурсів, а саме кількість qubits,
до виконання qubit-відображення на кшталт перетворення Jordan-Wigner.
На цьому кроці обчислюється ефективний гамільтоніан,
що дозволяє використовувати менше qubits у підсумку.
У нашому прикладі з 14 орбіталями
цей метод зменшує кількість qubits всього до шести.
Тепер ми можемо піти ще далі у цих скороченнях.
Можна використовувати різні відображення,
які є дещо складнішими за Jordan-Wigner.
Найпоширенішим прикладом є відображення за паритетом.
Відображення за паритетом відображає не заповненість орбіталей на qubits,
а паритет орбіталей на окремі qubits.
Ми не будемо вдаватись у математичні деталі тут,
але важливо знати, що це відображення містить додаткові
надлишковості, які можна використати для вилучення ще двох qubits.
Отже, наш приклад із 14 орбіталями скорочується з 14 qubits
до 6 qubits завдяки редукції активного простору, а потім до 4 qubits
завдяки скороченню двох qubits у відображенні за паритетом.
Давай коротко згадаємо ще одне перетворення.
Ще одним поширеним відображенням між ферміонним
і qubit-представленням є перетворення Bravyi-Kitaev.
Перетворення Bravyi-Kitaev використовує qubits для кодування інформації
як про число заповнення, так і про паритет квантового стану.
Перетворення Bravyi-Kitaev об'єднує інформацію про число заповнення та паритет
для базису молекулярних орбіталей розміру N:
тут знову використовується N qubits.
Однак інформація, що зберігається в кожному qubit,
тепер залежить від того, яким саме є цей qubit.
А саме: якщо індекс qubit парний,
він зберігає число заповнення відповідної
орбіталі, як у відображенні Jordan-Wigner.
Якщо індекс qubit непарний, qubit зберігає паритет певної
множини чисел заповнення. Перетворення Bravyi-Kitaev є найефективнішим,
коли кількість qubits наближається до степеня двійки.
Відображення Bravyi-Kitaev поєднує переваги Jordan-Wigner
і паритетного перетворення.
Воно зменшує кількість qubits, на які діє кожен член гамільтоніана,
що важливо для квантового моделювання, оскільки члени,
що діють на велику кількість qubits у гамільтоніані,
потребують довших circuits для свого моделювання.
Це означає, що глибина circuit
зменшується завдяки перетворенню Bravyi-Kitaev, і загалом
ми можемо отримати кращі результати на реальному залізі.
Це покращення порівняно з перетворенням Jordan-Wigner,
яке дає гамільтоніан порядку N qubits.
Отже, у цьому відео ми розглянули методи відображення
ферміонного гамільтоніана на qubit-гамільтоніан.
У наступному відео ми побачимо, як найкраще вибрати стан
і варіаційну форму або circuit.
Побачимось там.